so I refuse any longer to be intimidated
or browbeaten by the tears if you had
any heart in you you would be crying for
the Palestinians not for what you
done now Dr Professor Norman finlin not
one country in the entire Arab world
wants to help them why this is
I'll answer one simple sentence any of
the European countries or the United
States want Jews before the Nazi
Holocaust maybe the Jews were like the
Palestinians they were so horrible or as
the current Israeli government calls
them Human animals you think that's the
reason you think that's the reason
you're smiling but your stupid smirk
won't change the fact that the very
argument you used it was used by Hitler
to justify the extermination of the Jews
nobody wants them because they're so
terrible and so horrible you're a Nazi
speaking now in those kinds of arguments
this is another key point that they
always bring out to
justify the ethnic cleansing the
genocide that's happening right now
what's happening Israel is basically
saying get the hell out of Gaza we are
coming full force for Hamas we do not
want to kill civilians please leave now
what is Hamas saying saying stay we need
you we need you to stay here why because
Hamas uses its citizens to protect Hamas
whereas Israel uses the IDF to protect
its citizens let me say that again Hamas
uses its citizens to protect Hamas as
human Shields whereas the IDF will use
uh will protect its citizens so if you
if if um if Israel if Hamas put down all
their guns all their weapons there would
be peace if Israel put down all their
guns and all their weapons they would
all be dead the moral equivalency is not
even close so human Shields it's often
repeated you've probably got sick of
answering the question but this is
something that's used to justify the
attack on
civilians human shield the human
shielding isn't a precisely defined term
in international law
uh but it generally ref refers to the
conscription the forceable conscription
of
civilians uh in order to uh
protect
either uh combatants or
military
sites that's more or less as I said it's
not a uh a legal
term uh the evidence the it has not been
legally defined but that's generally how
people use the term the forcible
conscription of civilians to either
Shield combatants or to Shield military
sites now I've read the entire
record hum uh human rights record on the
Israel Palestine conflict since I would
say probably since yeah since around
2000 I've read before 2000 but
exhaustively beginning 2000 no actually
I would say even earlier probably the
first in t so that would be
1988 uh there's been no
uh record of
Hamas using I I have to be careful about
these things because we're covering a
long period Hamas doesn't even emerge
until the late
1980s so let's just go to 2000 the first
major
operation uh Israel's operations its
high-tech massacres uh occurs in
operation defensive shield in 2002 when
it went into
Janine uh when Israel went into Janine
the city of
Janine so you look at a whole period
let's just take one example which I
which has been the most exhaustively dou
umented and that's the operation castled
in
20089 uh Amnesty International did the
most exhaustive study of what happened
during what amnesty called the 22 days
of death and destruction namely the
Israeli what Israel calls the operation
castled and it found no
evidence that Hamas engaged in human
shielding now there are two further
points I have to make Point number one
there is a
distinction in international law between
what's
called
um human shielding which is I said is
not a legally defined term and what's
take what's called taking all feasible
precautions taking all feasible
precautions in the course of combat not
to endanger civilians now that does have
a legal
standard um and a legal
definition you in the course of combat
you're required by international law to
take all feasible
precautions to avoid civilian
casualties and there have been some
cases as with inevitably be the case
when you're dealing with the most
densely populated place on God's Earth
there are going to be some places where
Hamas is going to be firing a rocket or
a projectile from a civilian area that's
just
unavoidable given the nature of
Gaza so there has been some claims some
claims not a lot but some and we want to
stay faithful to the factual record that
Hamas hasn't taken all feasible
precautions
to wage combat away from
civilians but there's a second side to
the story which all the human rights
organizations document yes there has
been a lot of human shielding there has
been a lot of human shielding
going on in Gaza but you know who's
conducting the human shielding it's
Israel Israel takes civilians and fires
from behind them Israel isra wow wow so
this it this is documented by all the
human rights organizations
controversial Israel takes civilians
when it takes over an apartment building
and places the civilians in front of the
windows and then fires from behind the
civilians Israel takes civilians and
forces them to sit be sit beside
tanks there has been human shielding and
it's been
widely and repeatedly
documented yes Israel has carried out
the human shielding I cannot leave
without giving you a gift if you're not
yet Muslim and you're tuning in to see
what these Muslim are talking about and
you like a free copy of the Quran go
ahead and visit theen show.com we'll
take care of the postage and everything
and get it delivered to you and if you
still have some questions about Islam
call us at 1 800
66247 52 we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you assalam alaykum